突然ですか皆さんに一つ質問があります
法律は絶対にも守らないできないのですか
少し抽象的かもしれませんねいいかいます
法律を守ることは絶対的に正しいのですか
こんにちは私の名前は高倉人に東京の中古一貫校に通う高校1年生です
私は野球が大好きれ野球部のマネージャーをやっています北にも本と映画とももそして
司法が大好きです
私はおととしの夏から約1年間藩士法に関する発信活動研究活動を進めてきました
そのきっかけ学校のファースの家プロジェクトという活動です
個人の研究活動で一つ課題を設定する必要がありました
私は最初貧困解決について取り組みたいと思っていました
私のお母さんは pp が小さな村で生まれて12人家族の貧しい環境で育ちました
そのことを小さい頃から聞いていた私は貧困というのすごく身近な課題として感じてい
ました
しかしいざリサーチしてみると子どもの貧困のための子供食堂
大人の品このための生活保護世界の貧困のための国際的支援
もうすでに多くの方々がさまざ
雨な視点から健康について取り組んでいることを知りました
学校の支援を受けられるせっかくの機会だからあまり取り組まれていない活動に
向き合いたいと思い私は改めて課題を設定しようと考えていました
そんなときに一つ銀行に関するある記事を読んだのです
あるお母さんが貧しさゆえに食べ物を盗んでしまったため犯罪者となってしまったと
いう内容の記事です
これが記事を読み終えた私の大生でした
食べを盗むないといけないほど貧困に苦しんでいた
そのお母さんとその子供はある意味被害者です
社会の被害者です
被害者だった時は社会から見向きもされなかったのに
加害さとなった途端になぜ社会から注目され
鯖からないといけないのでしょうか
私は大きなやかんを覚えました
そしてさらに日本の犯罪者の現状について調べていくと
驚愕の事実を知りましたん
日本の再犯率が50%刑務所を出た2人に1人がもう一回刑務所に戻っているのです
この再犯率が高いという背景には
出所者の苦しみがあります
或許受刑者からこういう話を聞きますか
出所後は友達や親族との関係が断ち切られているため
連帯保証人となる人が見つからずお家を借りられなかったといいます
住居がないと職に就くことができません
そして仕事ができないと生活するためのお金が得られません
そして生活に困窮してしまう人が多くいるのです
そこから窃盗やヤクザ詐欺グループなど再び
違法行為に手を染めてしまう人が少なくないのです
この現状を知り私はさあ犯罪者の社会復帰支援に取り組むことを決めました
そして去年の2月にはインスタグラムで情報発信アカウントを開設しました
しかしそこで活動していく売れ一つ気がかりなことがありました
私はずっと犯罪者犯罪さって言ってるけどそれは実は犯罪者を
異星人として見なしている椅子機が自分の中にあることに気づいたのです
しかし犯罪さっていうのは異星人じゃありません
私たちと同じ人間です
しかし私たちと違うのは犯罪さというのは効率を破ってしまったという大きな過ちを
犯してしまった人間です
そうユーザーその法律っていうのは何だろうと思って私は法律について勉強するように
なりますか
そこで徐々に大きくなっていった疑問があります
それは私私が最初にみんなに聞いた
法律は絶対に守らないといけないのかという疑問です
この疑問にどうやって答えようとずいぶん悩みました
その中で一つ数学的な考え方を思い出しました
メイダイトロン星という単元です
みんな多分勉強から抜け出せると思ったのにと思って見に来てくれている方もいると
思いますか
すいませ少しだけ明大についての説明にスポーツ付き合ってください
明大っていうな a は bd r という命題があるとします
この命題が正しいもしくは間違っているっていうことを証明するためには小さな命題を
2つ立ってます
1個目が a ならば b である3個目が
b ならば adr ということです
さらに a だけれど b でない b だけれど家でないっていう判例が一つでも3
つに使えばその命題は間違っているということになります
この説明だけじゃちょっとわかりにくいと思うのでここで一つ例を出したいと思います
アジア人は赤間がいいということを証明してみましょう
星座一つ目
アジア人ならば頭がいい
+かに野口英世は倍力や
黄熱病といった研究で世界的に名を挙げたし世界一の自動車会社とやった自動車の設立
者がって日本人の
とやたキーちろさんですよね
いやいやでもアジア人だけど勉強が得意じゃない人
成績が良くない人は者らに言いますよね
アジア人ならば頭がいいというのは間違っていると思います
水産に米頭が良ければアジア人がある
いやーこれも判例いっぱいあると思います
例えば
チーズもちゅらチーズとかチェダーチーズとかいろいろあると思いますけどその
cheeza
切りさで発明されました
そしてパンフランスパンとかくらーさんとか美味しいですけどそのパンティいうのは
エジプトで初めて作られました
そしてパンをトーストするためのトースターこれはアメリカのトーマスエジソンによっ
て開発されました
私たちが今チーズトーストを食べられているのはこの3カ国のおかげなんです
この3国3カ国どれもアジアの国じゃないですよね
これを頭いいと言わないのであれば誰をあってもいいというのでしょうか
頭が良ければアジア人があるっていうのを間違っていると言えます
だからアジア人は頭がいいっていうのは絶対的に正しくないということになるんです
この考え方を私は法律に当てはめてみました
ここで証明しようと思ったの法律を守ることは正しいということです
それじゃあ1個目
法律を守っていればそれは正しいことである
これはどうでしょ
ここでパップ判例が思い浮かんだ人もいると思います
最近話題になっている誹謗中傷とかい爪とかがこの代表的な判例になるのです
現在の法律 the 版千房中傷とかいじめっていうのは犯罪とはなりません
法律を持っていることです
だけどそれは正しいことと言えますか
決して言えないと思います
このように法律を守っていたとしてもそれが正しいとは限らないのです
生産に米正しければそれは法律を持っていることになるということはどうでしょう
ちょっと専門的な話になりますか狂気携帯罪という犯罪があります
これは狂気となるなり得るものを正当な使用目的なく
持ち運ぶという次です
例えば野球で使う金属バット車におきっぱなしにするとします
これは狂気系大豆系滞在として違法になるのです
だけどバットきっぱなしにするっていうのは間違っている行為なのでしょうか
そんなことはないと思います
だから正しければそれは法律を持っていることになるっていうのを間違っているという
ことになります
司法というのを英語で言うと justice system
正義の精度という意味になります
このこともあり私はずーっと司法は正義のためにあるんだと思ってました
ん
だけど今の照明でツアー違うということを知りました
法律を守っていたとしてもそれは間違っているこういいかもしれない
正しい声をしていたとしてもそれは違法かもしれない
つまり法律を守ることは絶対的に正しいのかという質問へのアンサーは
のということになるんです
ここでもう一つ疑問が浮かびました
こんな絶対的に正しくもない貴族の集まりである法律というのは何のために存在して
いるのでしょうか
このモヤモヤを私は今どきの若者ながらツイッターに空けてみました
そしたらリプライの中に一つピンとくるものがありました
社会の秩序のためにある
簡潔な1分が顔面に浮かんでました
これは見て私はこれがあって思いました
+かに司法は正義のためでも被害者のためにもんありません
国がスムーズに動けるように
国民が居心地よく過ごせるようにあるんです
ここで少し違和感を感じませんか
こんな国民皆が居心地よく過ごせるための氏族というみんなが望んでいるはずのものを
何で破ってしまう人がいるのでしょうか
しかし貴族っていうのは破る人がいる前提で作られるものです
私たちの社会いった法律という名前の規則を破ってしてしまった人たちが犯罪者となっ
てしまうのです
しかしここで少し違和感を感じませんか
みんなが居心地よく過ごすための規則というものなんで破ってしまうのでしょうか
4話がずれてしまいますかみなさんは今の自分が今のバスで今の性格でいられる理由を
考えたことありますか
ここで自分の家族とか友達の顔が浮かんだ人多いと思います
私も今お父さんとお母さんそしてお兄ちゃんの顔が浮かびました
人っていうのは確実に環境に影響されながら育ちます
それは犯罪者も例外じゃありません
しかし影響というのは良い影響と悪い影響があります
虐待を受けたいじめを受けた
そういう悪い影響幼少期に
経験した人たちは趣向が歪んで相撲も安いです
そしてそのゆがんだ思考はみんなが居心地よく過ごすということへの大きな壁となって
しまうのです
実際に受験者の1/2は虐待を受けた経験を持つ
受験者のほとんどはい事務に携わった経験を持つ
という調査報告が出ています親にもっと愛情を注がれていれば
せずにもっと気にかけてもらえていれば防げた事件は多くあります
いやでも虐待をされた人の中でもいじめを開けた人の中でも犯罪者じゃなくて普通に
生活しとしてる人もいるのではないか
を言う人もそう思う人も多いと思います私もそう思いました
ということは虐待やいじめといった環境的要因以外にも個人的8ヒートいうものがある
はずです
皆さんは責任能力の調査という言葉を聞いたことありますか
これは裁判でよく使われる言葉です
加害さが正常な心持ちで自覚を持って犯行に及んだかを調査するものです
この調査が実在するというのは過去に責任能力がない人が加害者となってしまったと
いうケースが多かったということを示します
実際に責任能力がないと言って無罪になった人も多くいます
こういう人たちは精神の精神の障害頭の病気といういったものを抱えていることが多い
です
このように障害とか病気といった個人的容易も人を犯行に至らせてしまう事の一つなん
このように私は人が判然犯してしまうという背景には虐待とかいじめとかっていう環境
的要因
そして障害とか部僚機と彼の個人的要因があると話しました
しかしこの2つには大きな共通点があります
両者とも生きづらさを抱えていた総数派であったということです
しかし虐待のある環境で生まれたから
障害を持ったから出る生まれたから犯行に至る犯行に及んでしまう
そういう現実おかしくないですか
少数派という言葉は jaxa という言葉とセットで少数派 jaxa という言葉
としてよく使われます
だけど少数派だ生まれたからといってザク砂となってしまう
ておかしくないですか
虐待的な環境で生まれたとしても障害を持った体で生まれたとしてもそうじゃない人と
同じように同じような機会を得て普通の生活ができる
そんな社会が理想なんじゃないんですか
犯罪者を許せと言いません他の人の人気を奪ってしまった犯罪者が一番悪いというのは
事実です
しかし犯罪者をただ悪と決めつけて隔離するだけでは犯罪加害はやめ
やみませんし犯罪加害が闇うやまないと犯罪被害も減りません
犯罪被害がない社会を目指すためには犯罪加害と向き合う必要があるのです
しかし被害者や被害西族加害者や加害さ家族など当事者の方々は生きるだけで精一杯の
人も多くいます
加害者と向き合って加害者の破壊系を理解するということはとてもできない状況にいる
人が多くいます
だからこそ私たち
被害者でも被害水族でも加害者でも加害者家族でもない私たち
運良く普通という生活を受ける送ることができる私たちが立ち上がる必要があるんです
当事者じゃない私たちが立ち上がって加害者の背景を理解するということは社会全体で
日外をなくすことにつながりますそして
日外をなくすことは被害をなくすこと
無実な人が来る済むということが減るということです
次に付けるの報道を見たとき組みあがってくる光を1回抑えて考えてみてほしいです
この加害者はどういう環境で育ったんだろう
なんでこんな事件が起こったんだろう
こういう事件がこれからなくなるためにはどうすればいいんだろう
一人ひとりが自分に問いかける社会一人一人が犯罪というものを自分ごととして考える
社会
それは加害のない社会被害のない社会になる
私はそう信じています